[Music]
would you prefer if this was an
interview on bikes right now
absolutely not have you ever have you
ever done a class for 600 people never
would you want to try yes right after
this meeting the Quad Ruth thank you so
much for being here for coming to
Stanford for being a part of the view
from the top program we have a lot to
cover we do thank you if it's all right
can we just jump right in let's do it so
I want to take us back all the way back
you described some very key moments in
your childhood
as being pivotal to the successes and
challenges and the obstacles you
ultimately overcame both personally and
professionally and a lot of that comes
from dance
what role did dance play in your
childhood it played a huge role
I discovered ballet classes when I was
eight years old my mother decided it
would be a good idea she said I was
getting a belly thanks mom and so she
put me in dance class little did she
know she basically created a monster in
that I just took to it immediately and
there was something about dancing that
just made me feel great it was an escape
and back to my mother she was she was a
difficult woman she was narcissistic
there wasn't much room for me it wasn't
much room for my voice and so in
retrospect when I look back it made
sense that I got so addicted to dancing
because it was it became my way of
expressing myself without words without
a voice and I think in in your story
there's so much grit and perseverance
that I think explains a lot of where
where you were able to get to and you
describe overcoming challenges like the
relationship with your mother that often
get overlooked when we talk about the
typical type of challenges here in
Silicon Valley or leadership and
entrepreneurship could we spend a minute
just on those types of setbacks what was
it like even in a household and in your
relationship with your mother trying to
fit into someone else's definition
success on such a personal context well
it had major repercussions for me
because growing up with a mother like
that your self-esteem is not going to be
very high and if you're always deferring
to someone and that person is always
telling you that they know more than you
do it would make sense it would be very
hard to build any kind of confidence so
that kind of really spelled out my
future and I'm a huge proponent of
therapy and and we might get to that
later but it was really the work that I
did in therapy that helped me the most
in terms of discovering Who I am why I
am Who I am and how to build the
confidence to which had gotten me to
where I've gotten to and just staying on
that point for a minute you described in
your memoir that years later after
launching very successful brands and
being a very successful entrepreneur in
almost any dimension that you look at
entrepreneurship from you were divorced
and not yet remarried and every winter
was it your mother would write a card
saying here's to a better year next year
yes and I know that seems extreme but
when I read it I felt that that actually
is quite relatable there are people in
all of our lives where they demand
something that we feel we have to go
uphold what was it like struggling
through that version success that wasn't
your own I mean it was part generational
I would say from for my mother but
actually the words were the same thing
every year hopefully this year will be a
better better year that was after I said
I started SoulCycle so when I say
generational what she meant every year
when she wrote these cards was hope I
hope you find a man and I find it
interesting to myself that it took me a
long time after divorce
to really set it settle into a
relationship with a man and I
no if I subconsciously knew that I
really shouldn't go that route I really
need to figure out myself first before
that falls into place and going right
there to that moment in life where you
describe being divorced with two young
daughters I think there were six years
old is that right what was going through
your mind is the next step both
personally and then professionally it
seems like would follow later honestly
Mike I had no idea I was a fish out of
water
I made this difficult decision to leave
the marriage 6-year old twin girls in
tow
I was now a single mother didn't have
much on the financial front and had to
figure out my life again having no idea
how to even start and that was when I
found spinning walk us through that
because today's spinning is I mean do we
have any SoulCycle fans there's flywheel
folks in the audience yeah Wow thank you
that's amazing so today it is it is part
of a lexicon it's in our in our culture
Society but what year was it when you
started spinning what was the landscape
like because I imagine is very different
than today so I was again newly out of
the marriage embarking on this entirely
foreign new life and you know when
you're going through a trauma one thing
that I learned is really important is to
take care of yourself and stay healthy
and and strong and so I had a gym
membership at what was the Reebok Club
on the Upper West Side of Manhattan at
the time and it was this beautiful
full-service gym that offered every kind
of group fitness you could imagine
swimming pool basketball court really an
incredible place and I was able to keep
my gym membership with the divorce and
so I went there every day and I used to
see these spin classes going on and I
found it very intriguing it was kind of
a floor-to-ceiling glass room dark room
was full the sound of the wheels club
music blaring and I thought that looks
interesting but I was intimidated and
I didn't know if I could really get
myself in there by myself and try it but
I did and literally within the first
class I knew that this was something
beyond exercise it felt like an
experience for me it was a cathartic
experience I felt that in the 45 minutes
from beginning to end there was almost a
mini transformation I got off the bike
at the end of the class and felt
empowered and felt that I could really
conquer my day and the challenges that
presented themselves as a quick timeout
to that I love how in business school we
do cases and courses and six-month
learning programs to try to have a light
bulb moment that you got getting on a
bike one day yes okay
immediately yeah sounds like you took
the shortcut thanks for that perspective
anytime so you get into spinning it
sounds like you learned a lot about
yourself first it wasn't a lightbulb
moment necessarily - oh I need to go
create a brand what did you find out
when you did some of the soul-searching
that seemed to come from getting into
the bike it really helped me realize how
much strengths I needed to build and
again that this there was something
about this that allowed me to recognize
that this was the way I was going to do
it and it it just showed me the
importance of confidence and believing
in in myself and believing in my ideas
and you know that my mother really
didn't know everything in that that type
of learning I think in a school like the
GSB where there's a very touchy-feely
mentality to approaching business that
resonates I'm sure with us in the
audience but can you break it down to
what that actually meant for going later
into business and how you applied some
of that personal learning into actually
making a business around it well I
really focused a lot on on my experience
and how it helped me and you know very
quickly I realized
everybody has trauma everybody has
problems and challenges in their life I
saw what it did for me and I so believed
in it that I just wanted to share my
experience with everyone else and I
wanted everyone else to have the same
chance to empower themselves and so that
was one of the you know motivating
forces in my getting to where I got to
with this concept of spinning so yeah do
you remember that conversation you had
where it all of a sudden started to come
together with your co-founders at the
time or your would-be co-founders in
starting SoulCycle you know one of the
co-founders approached me with the idea
it was an idea I'd dreamed about but
never had the capital and she did and so
you know she clearly she was a fan of
mine a big writer in my class and
clearly recognized my passion for it she
didn't know anything about teaching spin
or what went into it and so she depended
on me to be the face of the business and
to provide the method and and so she she
definitely appreciated it and as the
discussions got going you write in that
quote it had been a quarter century
since I gave up on my dream to become a
professional dancer and this is on the
brink of starting a brand and at that
time a fledging startup yes what's going
through your mind the night before you
start SoulCycle good night before we
opened yep a lot of pride and
appreciation really for everything that
led up to it you know we hear this a lot
but I lived it and it's so true that
everything we do in our life and
everything that creates this path that
we take contributes to where we land and
you brought up the dance classes before
they so tied in to the spin class that I
eventually helped to create and when I
say that what I mean is I was obsessed
with music from an early age and through
dance classes I learned so much about
music and different genres of music
being a dancer I choreographed to music
I knew how to move to music and really
to a certain extent what I did was I
just transferred that experience onto a
bike you know the discipline it takes to
to be a dance student and to grow up as
a dancer and become a professional
dancer that also transferred to the spin
class you know when I started SoulCycle
we decided that people should applaud
after the class the instructor puts a
lot into it you know especially when
you're going into a boutique experience
you're paying up for it and you're
paying for an instructor spending two
hours the night before making his or her
playlist and the applause is also for
each other and for encouraging the
community I mean that's just a simple
thing that I learned from dance class
and the other really key ingredient to
the success of boutique fitness is the
personal connection that we would make
with our riders and again no different
from a dance class if I was in a dance
class and my dance teacher said
beautiful job Ruth that took me through
my day that made my day
and so in a spin class if you point out
someone in the class if you make that
personal connection they're coming back
the next day so you start SoulCycle and
plot twists it works what did you learn
from that bootstrapping experience
because it wasn't that you went out you
raised a lot of money you figured it out
in fact we can get to the growth part
later you were against expanding super
fast and getting off to the races you
describe a moment where in your first
Center I believe they wouldn't allow you
to put signage on the outside of the
street entrance so you made it a cool
have to know someone thing to walk
through a gym and get to the back near
the exit to find that this whole cycle
gym what were the learnings there from
doing it yourself and not raising
capital well truthfully that was
completely luck I mean we signed the
lease and it was after we signed the
lease that the landlord said oh by the
way no signage and we thought
what are we gonna do and because we were
in the back of a building you can see us
from the street and Elizabeth one of my
co-founders came up with the idea of
just putting this rickshaw outside
painting it yellow and putting the name
of our business on it to attract
attention but again it eventually became
just just what you said people had to
know about it too to go there and again
completely unintentional but it took on
this kind of cool factor and you had to
you had to know someone to know that it
was there and you know in terms of a
learning lesson I mean that one we just
had no idea but it but it worked and and
it's interesting I believe a lot in kind
of trickle-down theory and that the aura
that you create in your business has a
lot to do with who's at the top and the
founders and you know eventually the
partnership didn't work out and and the
truth is my two co-founders were similar
and to each other but very different
from me and and I feel that the business
took on a lot of their personality
interestingly when I started flywheel
with two men the dynamic was completely
different there was a certain respect
that the three of us had for each other
respect for each other's expert areas of
expertise and we had a very different we
created a very different aura at
flywheel and to summarize it you know I
would always talk about soul cycle
eventually becoming a very exclusive
feeling having a very exclusive feeling
while flywheel had a very inclusive
feeling we were about including everyone
every shape size and color at a soul
cycle took on a certain I'm blanking on
the word but there was like a prestige
about going to soul cycle and again no
judgment here it worked and you know
obviously
cycle became huge and and so both both
personalities worked but they were just
very different can you talk a little bit
more about partnership I feel like when
you decide to go after something who you
go in with is probably the most critical
piece this seems as you describe it
somewhat happenstance as you were
approached by one of the co-founders
where was the tension ultimately in
terms of thinking about growth what you
all wanted what were the key learnings
from them really important question and
I get this all the time about choosing
partners in business and you know the
bottom line is obviously there's no
guarantee ever you know sometimes I
think about the fact that my two
co-founders of SoulCycle or two women
who I didn't know for a long time and I
thought well maybe you should only you
know go into business with someone you
do know for a long time but that's not
the case either I actually just heard a
story of two friends who started a
business and knew each other for 25
years and sure enough they start the
business money gets involved the
relationship fell apart and and the
business ship business partnership
dissolved but what I learned was it
really helps to know yourself when it
comes to picking partners and the truth
is when I made the agreement to go into
business with these two co-founders I
didn't know myself I really hadn't done
that kind of exploration and what I
ended up doing was I ended up with two
partners who were very much like my
mother and there were two people that I
my knee-jerk was to defer to them to
really let them overpower me and to not
have a voice I very easily slipped into
that role and as a result the
partnership fell apart and obviously
that was a huge learning lesson for me a
huge lightbulb moment for me the other
very obvious one was have really good
legal protection
when you go into a partnership and a
business and I didn't and unfortunately
I paid a big toll for that I appreciate
the the vulnerability because that's not
often a takeaway that people would want
to share so going into flywheel which a
lot of people when when they hear your
story
they they think of SoulCycle or they
think of flywheel they don't think that
you actually were behind both and you
described flywheel as your first true
business venture yes can you walk us
through that transition of leaving Seoul
I believe there was a stint as an
instructor for Seoul yes must have been
weird
I should take a deep breath in this
answer I our separation agreement was
signed and I was packing up my things to
leave and one of my cell cycle
co-founders looked at me and said where
are you going and I looked at her like
she had three heads and I said where am
I going I'm leaving
what do you mean you're leaving we
thought you'd just be an instructor is
what she said to me and I don't even
think I answered and I turned around and
started walking out and she kind of
yelled to me as I was walking out and
she said okay well just promise me that
whatever other offers you get will you
come back to me because I'll top that
offer and we really want you to be here
as just an instructor and I don't even
think I turned around and I and I left
and I got out there and here I was now a
single mom of two girls in high school
you know not in in a not in a very
strong position financially and I went
out there to see what I was going to do
next and the reality was it was still
very early in the industry and there
were no other boutique businesses at
that point so it really meant I would
have to go back to one of the big box
gyms and teach classes for 40 bucks
costs and I couldn't do it and so I went
back
I went back to her and I said okay well
I got this offer and then sure enough
she topped the offer very generously and
I decided to do it and it was one of the
hardest decisions I ever made and I did
it for two years and every day I walked
in to teach class I would have to look
at both of them and I always say I
probably you know grew a gray hair every
single day and it was torturous and it
never got any less torturous for two
years but what happened was I would walk
in and then I would get on my podium and
get on my bike and there I was in front
of all of my people that I brought in to
this business all the customers and they
didn't know what happened and that
helped a little bit eventually they did
obviously but um I would hit the play
button my class would start and all of
that negativity would just go away for
forty-five minutes because I was just up
there doing what I do which was
connecting with my people they connected
with me and we all had this cathartic
experience together and that's what got
me through it
lastly it was the summer of 2009 where I
was teaching a SoulCycle class and it
was then that I met my future co-founder
of flywheel so if I hadn't been there I
guess that never would have happened and
right before meeting this the fact that
would be founder of flywheel was there a
moment because I think we tend to
glorify entrepreneurship as it's a no
brainer must do don't look back
was there a moment where you did look
back and you and you think I'm now
caring for a family solely on my
shoulders this this venture didn't work
out and it's a painful next two years
did you ever think about what life could
have been had you not taken that risk
the risk with SoulCycle no because I
knew that
in you know despite the negativity and
the trauma I learned a lot and there
were so many positive parts of it so no
I didn't regret it at all and going into
flywheel you're now at a point where
you've pioneered spinning and spin
classes in that that sense of community
and you've built a brand around at once
what did you feel like you could do
different in a space that you you you
defined and built already and now what
would be a competitor
well my co-founder flywheel made it very
easy because he came up with this idea
of attaching technology to the bike and
bringing this little computer screen to
the to the bike so that we could finally
measure exactly what we were doing on
the bike how hard we were working you
know what our resistance levels were how
fast we were going and I knew that that
would change the experience
significantly and I doubted it in the
beginning because SoulCycle for me was
so much about the mindful component of
the ride and I thought I don't know if
we have to focus on numbers we might you
know compromise that component the
mindful component and that's so
important to me and they they just
begged me just get on the bike and just
go in there by yourself and and work
with it and see what you think and I did
and in that period of time forty minutes
I knew I knew this was going to be a
game-changer because I could still do
the mindful part and have the numbers
and I just felt like this was taking it
to the next level you describe that your
partner's had a different approach you
talked about it in terms of personality
but there's also a business nugget where
they felt that you could actually grow
the business by attracting folks who
otherwise wouldn't be cyclers or spin
goers what was that process like of
actually identifying a new market
audience where there wasn't one already
you know this business is this type of
business is honestly so word-of-mouth
you know for
the entire time I was at soul cycle and
flywheel we never advertised once so
again it always came back to connecting
with people and I connected with the
flywheel clientele pretty much in the
same way I did with the soul cycle
clientele and it was just about making
Pinsky's me making it personal and make
making people feel noticed at the end of
the day that's what that's what we all
want an interesting counterbalance to
that as you describe that empathy should
be in moderation when going forward in
business which also runs counter to a
lot of the things we hear about
especially today and how do you lead
with empathy build a business around
empathy you obviously have a you have a
product and a service that made people
feel a certain way but you also caution
to use it in moderation why's that
sometimes they can get you into trouble
we we were very big on empathy and and
it helped us in terms of the culture we
built with our employees and with our
customer base and so I'm going to talk
about the positive part first which is
again making everyone feel important
making our maintenance person feel as
important as someone on the executive
leadership team by doing that everybody
has you know this desire for the
business to be successful and that's
what you want you want everyone to be as
motivated as you are as a founder and
sure enough that was a great way to get
that sometimes when you get too personal
then it could you know the business part
could can be compromised and you just
get too much into the weeds and I
wouldn't recommend that
but um especially again in this business
because with instructors you're dealing
with a very creative ego driven group
and that can be a slippery slope
sometimes to zoom out a little bit you
look at the brands that you successfully
built and led with soul cycle and
flywheel I was in a classroom last week
that had a very interesting discussion
around the place in society for brands
that make you feel a certain way and
people maybe some folks here in the
audience at least others that I know
have talked about soul cycle or flywheel
as another form of therapy it's religion
it's like my church at what point did
that start to happen where people would
would it would share with you that type
of reaction and is that okay for a brand
to fill that void I think so and it
happened right away and the major reason
that people started to feel comfortable
connecting with me because I can only
speak for myself was because of my
willingness to be vulnerable in front of
people and I found that if I was
vulnerable it made them feel comfortable
enough to be vulnerable and it's when
two people are vulnerable that they
connect and look we certainly know in
this day and age of living the most
efficient life we can and technology and
everything going digital it we need to
connect more than ever I mean it's a
human need that will never go away and
so that's why I think this business is
this type of business is so important
and here to stay I think that's a nice
transition into the industry as a whole
you got into the health and wellness
space when it was really nascent there
weren't the soul cycles and other brands
out there now on every corner in any
neighborhood especially places like Palo
Alto and elsewhere but a lot of Metro
cities now you have a million different
options health and wellness is an 80
billion dollar industry where is there
space for innovation if at all so it's a
good question because you know in
thinking about the future of all of this
you know we're seeing what's happening
with the industry we're seeing how it is
going into the digital realm and look in
spinning we're seeing about the success
of peloton and the industry is
definitely changing
with with the amount of choices out
there which you just spoke about it's
very different you know when I started
soul cycle and flywheel those were the
days of people taking six spin classes a
week so you know what a formula of for
success in our businesses but now there
are so many choices I call it exercise
snacking people are people are not
coming to spin class six days a week
there they're coming twice a week and
then they're going to berries twice a
week and then they might be boxing or a
couple days a week on their palate on at
home and and I don't have the answers
actually it's very interesting to me as
to where this will go and where this
will head health and wellness I think
will always be a huge industry moving
forward because of the challenges we all
have in life in general and people are
finally starting to recognize that we
need to take care of ourselves
and we want to live long lives and and
kind of this is how to do it but I'm
very interested in seeing where the
fitness industry particularly goes and I
do feel that there will always be room
for the group fitness part of the
fitness industry I think people always
will need this human connection that I
just spoke about the convenience factor
will not go away and people will want to
be able to have the option of doing it
in their home as well so I think there
will be both that peloton story just
fascinates me because that's who you are
taking people out of their basement
stationary bike and bringing them to
their neighborhood gym and giving them a
sense of real in-person community and
now 15 years later you have a company
that just went public saying you know
what let's bring you back into your
basement and take you away from the very
thing that you described people seeking
which is community is that here to stay
well I'm gonna give John Foley a shout
out at the founder of peloton he used to
be a big fly wheeler and and Soul cycler
and a more moral yes of course yeah
so I actually was just going to talk
about the lawsuit but I better not
okay yeah just between us friends here
on the road this is definitely gonna
bite me in the ass but um no I mean
there's there's a lawsuit going on
obviously I won't go into the details
but there's a patent lawsuit going on
against flywheel from peloton and it's
just it's very amusing to me because
John modeled the peloton bike after the
flywheel bike so that was a big you know
scratch my head moment but um but what I
was going to say was I was going to give
him a compliment because he and and were
actually friends we really are on good
terms he at peloton they actually did a
really good job I think of bringing the
community aspect into this at-home
experience and I was actually really
impressed and surprised by it but you
know they have built a huge community at
Pala I'm sure you've all read about it
and it's part of the reason for their
success I mean peloton riders having
conventions basically in getting getting
together all over the world so so he's
actually done a great job of doing that
but I'm also hearing a lot in in terms
of people missing the group experience
the live experience and and wanting it
back and we were actually having this
conversation before I came out here but
another phenomenon that's taking place
is a lot of kind of bigger businesses
and corporations are now getting into
this sector and you know SoulCycle was
acquired flywheel was acquired and the
businesses have changed a lot because
they've gotten more corporate and
they've gotten less personal and I've
heard a lot of complaints about that
from riders at both SoulCycle and
flywheel that they miss the way it used
to be and they miss the community and
and the attention that was given to the
individual because they've all because
it's been lost and so that kind of
speaks to
wanting to bring it back full circle to
a certain degree to bring the
conversation back full circle one of the
things we spoke right before coming on
stage about was you know what what
lessons you would give yourself as a
teenager thinking about the course of
your life as an entrepreneur the
business takeaways you describe some of
them but also we have a lot of business
school students in the audience now and
a big reason people come to programs
like view from the top is we're about to
go in a lot of different ways and I
think the power of storytelling is that
there might be a nugget you can share
that maybe tomorrow maybe in five years
or ten years you look back on and you
think that was actually really helpful
that was something I remember that story
I heard in in Ruth's narrative is there
anything that you'd want to make sure
you get out if there's one thing folks
can take home yes you know that question
is often verbalized by saying you know
what would you tell your 16 year old
self and and that's how I'm looking at
it and if I could do that and if I could
go back it what the message would be to
relax that we just we are not going to
have the answers when we're 16 we might
not have the answers when were 37 but we
put so much pressure on pressure on
ourselves in thinking that we should
know the answer and and we don't and I
think the comforting piece of it is that
every decision we make as we evolve and
grow up actually does play a part in
where we ultimately land and you know as
I was talking before about my dance
classes I thought I was going to be a
dancer that that idea fell through and
at the moment when it fell through I
felt like nothing but a failure and I
was you know clueless as to what I was
going to do next and again at that
moment I had no idea what a huge part my
experience with dance would play
in my future career and so so again it's
just everything happens for a reason as
trite as that is but it really does and
we learn an enormous amount with every
decision we make along the way and there
really is no wrong decision if it's okay
I'd love to end with a personal question
that I think you you touch on a little
bit or at least led me to want to ask in
your book you describe a very close
relationship with your father who I
believe passed away from cancer yeah and
you described a scene where you were at
his bedside and he said to you that and
I quote I'm ready to go I've
accomplished everything that I ever set
out to do and have enjoyed my life fully
and then you respond by saying that
quote in that moment as much as I
couldn't help feeling my own sorrow I
was also inspired by his courage and his
resolve a lot of times death makes us
think about our own mortality in certain
ways what did that have on you as you
think about the rest of your life
honestly I you know I I'm looking
forward to the rest of my life and
everything that's happened thus far
you know everything that that will
afford me in terms of my experiences but
that was a moment where I really thought
I just hope one day I can say that about
myself and I already feel like I can so
that feels really good
Thank You Ruth let's go to questions I
think we have a few from the audience
they were a pre-submitted sir okay
hi my name is Dan Knapp I'm a first year
MBA student and I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about some of
the leadership principles or lessons
that you took from being an instructor
on the podium and you carried into the
boardroom as a CEO yeah I think I would
answer that by again going back to the
empathy piece and I like to share with
people that you know going into business
I had absolutely no business experience
and I was raised in a family of
physicians and surrounded by my parents
friends who were all from the medical
community so I really didn't have a clue
and so when I look back I and look back
at my leadership leadership style I
think well you know what was my
leadership style and and where did it
come from and the truth is my biggest
experience was being a mom and and so I
looked at how I raised my children and
what my style was in raising my children
and the truth is I used a lot of
qualities that are typically attached to
women and empathy is certainly one of
them and I learned that the simple idea
of the importance of listening to people
would be really important in business as
well and listening to my employees and
and listening to what works for them and
what doesn't work for them listening to
their despair when they made a mistake
but then encouraging them that you could
learn from your mistake and let's see
what we can do with that again you know
typical ways in which I brought up my
children and so that was really what I
drew upon the most in terms of my
leadership style
hi my name is kana Hammond I'm an MBA
one and I have been to both SoulCycle
and flywheel many times so thanks for
bringing all of us that experience I'm
curious about you talked about how
important it was to help your clients
feel noticed and important and like
they're a part of a community I'm
curious about other elements that you
wanted to bring into both of these
brands as you were thinking about the
concepts and how you brought them to
life in the brands that you did create
you know it was about making people feel
comfortable in every way customer
service in general was huge in and is
huge in this in this field and in this
industry and you know that has to do
with not only making people feel good
but making everything easy for them and
starting flywheel you know was a huge
and sorry let me rephrase that
being second in an industry was a huge
advantage in many many ways because I
got to see what worked at soul cycle and
continue that and what didn't work and
improve upon it so a good way to answer
the question is when we started flywheel
we wanted to make signup more efficient
so it's all cycle literally everyone
walked in waited on line and signed up
on a list of you know a paper list they
still do and they still do yes and so
immediately a flywheel we thought you
know we're adding technology to the bike
so let's let's be consistent and let's
have small portable laptops set up in
our lobby area so people don't have to
wait in line and people can you know
sign up by themselves it's SoulCycle
people had to reach for their wallet and
pull out some cash for a bottle of water
and rent and shoe rental we made it all
inclusive in our price so every they
didn't have to pay for anything
it was all done already they didn't have
to wait in line to get shoes we had
personalized cubbyholes and we saw who
was coming to class ahead of time and
had their shoes waiting for them so
again customer service is huge hi I'm
Jen I'm a first year MBA thanks so much
for your time a question I have is
around somebody mentioned earlier I
think you know a lot of us an ideal
state would be to go to Spain maybe the
core power berries a few times a week
peloton at home I think you know the
reality is that's not accessible just
based on different income levels so I'm
curious how you think accessibility can
be incorporated into the wellness
industry and boutique fitness
particularly great question and it's
something I'm currently actually
thinking a lot about because there's no
question you know it's not the boutique
industry is really not very accessible
to everyone and I think that that's
really needed right now and I know I
happen to know of businesses that are
already in the works where they're
coming up with a less expensive bike
which will then allow a business that's
more accessible a less sorry a less
expensive at-home bike as well so I know
everyone's trying to think in that
direction right now and then I I think
it's so important hi my name is Laura
also an MVA one thanks so much for being
here my question was around the therapy
topic you mentioned I think it's so rare
to see someone as successful as you talk
about how important it was and I'm also
a big proponent of mental and physical
fitness so I was wondering for people
who maybe haven't tried it yet or even
people who have how would you describe
what therapy or other types of mental
fitness helped you change or come to
realize you touch on it a little bit but
maybe if you could talk more in depth
about what are some tangible things that
help people understand what mental
fitness could look like
I could give you I'm gonna give you two
anecdotes on that I had a very difficult
marriage uh so my ex-husband had anger
management issues just leave it at that
and and I stayed in it for a long time
way longer than I should have but I
can't really think of it that way
because it's who I was at that time
there was a reason why I was there and
it wasn't until therapy in fact my first
therapy session ever where I sat down
and I my motivation was my father was
dying and I had no idea how I was going
to go on with that and within the first
session I was asked about to describe my
marriage and I did and it was the first
time in my life that someone said to me
do you understand that that's actually
unacceptable behavior and I think I just
broke down in tears I mean that was a
life-changing moment for me
and that wouldn't have happened if I
didn't seek out a therapist and and that
really started my ball rolling in terms
of not only leaving the marriage but
starting to really learn about who who I
am and who I was
the second anecdote is was another
trauma it was about another trauma which
was the dissolution of my SoulCycle
partnership and I remember probably a
year ago I mean the dissolution happened
in 2007 its 2019 and probably a year ago
I sat in a therapy session and I said to
my therapist is there something wrong
with me because I can't seem to get past
this trauma like I still get really
upset and angry when I think about it is
there something wrong with me and she
looked at me and she said why would you
ever think there was something wrong
with you
why wouldn't you feel that anger today
it was
horrible horrible thing that was
incredibly helpful to me again just
another moment of putting things and
being able to put things in perspective
and and have self empathy you know a lot
of us don't really know that we have
permission to really feel for ourselves
we've all been through traumas you know
we've all had a lot of challenges
growing up and in our adult life and
taking a moment and understanding that
and acknowledge acknowledging that is
huge so we have one last thing to do
which is somewhat of a tradition here
called the lightning round uh-oh yep I'm
sure I am but I I took the liberty to
make a version two of that game just
because you're here and I thought it
might be fun we can see how this works
it's called who said it best Plato or
SoulCycle it's a very simple game so I
will say a quote and you will have the
option of saying is it a quote set in a
SoulCycle class or by Plato and then we
will if you want we can then ask the
audience you know to either kind of like
ask the audience question they can
either affirm or deny if that might be
the right question or right answer and
then all I'll share who said it wait I
have to say one thing I asked the same
question I was looking up some no
because that question profits to mine
can I see a raise of hands of anyone who
saw the Saturday Night Live cell-cycle
parody ok thank you this was an
inspiration of how inspiration for the
game it was so spot-on I don't know ok
question number one everyone listen up
here this is important quote open
yourself up to the possibility that the
best part of your life hasn't happened
yet
Plato or SoulCycle
my tricky right that's so easy
yeah do this in person when I wrote
these down I actually couldn't remember
who said what so I had to go back but I
have the answer here give a guess Plato
Plato what does the audience think it
was SoulCycle right now it was just a
warm-up I'm not giving them any credit
yeah you got another hour of these so
okay this is a personal favorite nothing
beautiful without struggle played over
SoulCycle Plato Plato or SoulCycle Plato
correct we're one for one if you're not
challenged you won't change soul cycle
soul cycle correct
inhale intention exhale expectations
soul cycle I bet you Plato would have
liked that though if that counts for
something
never discourage anyone who continually
makes progress no matter how slow Plato
or SoulCycle Plato Plato but a little
bit of disagreement there of course I
said all of these things yeah exactly
duh courage is knowing what not to fear
Plato or so later yeah
plate up nice alright and last one this
is probably the toughest one so okay if
you don't get this right tap it back
ladies and gentlemen thank you and let
us thank you for joining
[Applause]
[Music]